I'm Jim Hardin I'm the chair of the
columbia alumni association and on
behalf of my fellow board members many
of whom are in the room I too would like
to thank president Bollinger and the
panel for a motivational and informative
start to our weekend of alumni leaders
at Columbia which continues tomorrow all
day with programs in alumni leadership
connecting to to the University and
across the alumni constituencies and
being capped tomorrow evening with the
gala dinner to honor this year's 10
recipients of the columbia alumni medal
for conspicuous service to the
university it's my pleasure now to
introduce another Columbia alum an
alumnus of the business school senator
frank Lautenberg is now in his fifth
term of a career in the Senate devoted
to making life better for the residents
of New Jersey and indeed for the nation
unfortunately very busy in Washington as
you know these days his duties prevented
him from being able to join us for the
panel but he has made an extraordinary
effort to be here tonight and to join us
with some closing remarks please welcome
frank Lautenberg
thank you i don't know whether thank you
Jim Hardin and congratulations for your
hard work on behalf of Columbia the
alumni and I don't know whether closing
remarks means that after I get finished
talking or as I talked the house will
empty is that how to make silly jokes
when you make speeches you know and I
remember one time can you hear me in the
back I asked that question and someone
the back said no no some of the French
had I'll change places with you but it's
a it's a treat for me to be here and a
treat for me always to thank Columbia
whatever ways I can for the influence
that it had on my life and the the
opportunity to chat with you for a few
minutes is one that I wanted to do
because of my view of what life ought to
be like for those of us who have had the
good fortune to be able to have
developed skills or have good fortune in
their lifetime and so to give something
back and I theme I i saw i like very
much as the me generation to the wii
generation in the if you look at what
the definition of responsibilities are
today and we see that despite the fact
that colombia has this a choice location
in this great city and we thank
President a volunteer
for his good work having come here and
helping to lead colombiana new an
important change in its physical
existence but to be able to accommodate
more students and bring more good things
to the society in which we live and but
as we look at the responsibilities of
those of us who have had the fortune to
succeed and look now at the scope of the
obligation things now are different as
they I guess always in as years pass by
are different in so many ways unexpected
and at a pace that is hard to believe
and this will not be a long dissertation
I promise you but when you look at a
globalization and what it stands for and
technology and what it what the area
that we can cover so quickly it says
that we now understand as we've never
understood before the misfortune of
people across the globe of people who
desperately need help and call on us
call on us as a country and call on us
as members of the human race with the
conscience and wanting to give something
back for our good fortune and if I may
take just a few moments to draw on my
life I hope it doesn't sound true
pretentious but I've been so lucky I
joined the army when I was 18 years old
sometimes people say which were but with
spanish american or something
I joined the army when I was 18 the
leaving behind a very sick father very
young but very sick 42 years old and a
very young mother 37 years old and
having not brought any skills with them
when they were brought to America by
their parents searching for a better
life trite but true and little skills
and what does one do for a living my
father worked we lived in the city of
paterson new jersey in Milltown the
beginning of the Industrial Revolution
took place here Alexander Hamilton and
and the consequence of that wire
factories all over the place and my
father was a worked in a silk mill as
did his father and as did his brother
and apparently there were materials
there that were dangerous to health and
one of them was responsible for inducing
cancer my father his brother and their
father and they died very young my
father died after I am listed in the
Army at the age of 43 and suffered a
long period of a very painful existence
says in those days this does go back a
long time they didn't have the things
that would give you relief as we see it
now and my mother was left again a 37
year old widow without any particular
skills and I did my duty I served in
Europe during the war and my mother
worked got a white-collar job which was
unusual because she had no experience in
in a white-collar situations worked for
the Prudential Insurance Company able to
keep she and my sister her on my sister
going while I I was
away and I had no perspective on a
college education but it was there free
and available to me it was called the GI
Bill I'm sure you've all heard of it and
for me living not too far across the
river physically but miles and miles
away emotionally and psychologically I
went to Columbia I couldn't believe it
when I was accepted i think that was
part of the reward i got with the best
may be bypassed a s80 thank God they
weren't around at that time but in short
order I by the way I was in the last
undergraduate class at Columbia at the
business school now maybe they saw the
evil of their ways and decided no more
undergraduate students here we got to
get people who are ready to learn at a
different stage in life good fortune
followed me and I with two associates
started a company that now it's called
automatic data processing the company if
I could get some water please Lisa
automatic data processing we started
just the three of us the two fellows I
associated with with brothers and their
father also worked in the silk mills and
we worked hard and had the energy and
ADP today as 46,000 employees has we're
in 26 countries they it's not we I wish
it was with you when i get my payday bae
check but they succeeded succeeded very
well without me and and the company has
the longest growth record of any country
in american history at over ten percent
each and every year on the bottom line
for 42 years in the row 42 years oh
thank you i appreciate that doesn't
disturb any always have to watch out
when when the podium tilts your way what
time I've had the wrong end of the
happen to me so 42 years in a row we
were not primarily a computer service
the computer technology came along well
after we started a payroll processing
business and it enabled us to grow
rapidly from that point forward and we
were we did invent a business the
business was called outsourcing computer
technology was just a facilitating
process and so life was was good and I'm
very proud of the success that we
achieved there and I then decided after
many years 30 years to be precise that I
wanted to do something different that
America was so good to me so good to my
family despite the hardship so good and
what I didn't learn in my textbooks at
Columbia I learned from my exposure to
other opportunities in life than things
seen from the back of a little
neighborhood store that my folks would
buy every now and then because the mills
would close and as a consequence I felt
truly obliged I to do something that was
other than moving a business and doing
better but at the same time it didn't
fulfill my need to pay back I came to
the Senate in 1982 by the way I'm proud
to say I was then 58 years old so you
can do your own
patike comes up to 65 I think doesn't
but but anyway the I thought that if I
had a chance to serve one term in the
United States Senate it would have been
just reward for anything that I'd done
in my life but I liked it and after the
first term the first term i was elected
because adp was the the candidate I
didn't talk about me I talked about adp
everybody said anybody can create jobs
like that we had 16,000 employees at the
time comes along at just the right time
the theme then 1982 is jobs jobs jobs
same theme that we have today and so I
ran a second time and that turned out to
be pretty good i ran a third time people
New Jersey were still tolerant and they
let me do it again and then I decided
that I'd that was enough I wanted to do
something else and I couldn't think
about the else all I could think about
in the year 2001 when I which was the
year of my then retirement january two
thousand one all i could think about is
that year went along was 911 so what was
happening to our country on the edge of
a recession preparing to go to war and I
thought damn if I could only be back
there and dates once again came in to
help out the fellow who was running for
the office was two years later was
failing in his opportunity it seemed to
a win the election he was way behind in
the polls the governor called me and
asked if I would consider five weeks ago
October first 9 1992 got the wrong year
at 2002 showed I should have gone to
graduate school but what
sorry governor called and asked if I
would consider running again and he said
Frank I know that this is a heck of a
lot to ask but we are going to lose this
seat the fellow running was 20 points
behind in the polls and we were five
weeks to go to to the election he said
would you consider it said running again
I'd have to think about it ok so I her
hand again and I am now in my fifth term
i am the longest forgive the immodesty
but I'm the longest serving senator ever
in the history in New Jersey and having
cast the largest number of votes ever I
wrote laws like I stopped I'm
responsible for you not being able to
get a cigarette and airplanes forgive me
hi he said it couldn't be done but they
didn't know a fellow from Paterson he
can take them Bella out of the city
which he can't take the city out of the
thought and I fought hard and we were
able to succeed and and I've written
other laws that affect people's lives
for instance i was able about 10 years
ago to write law to stop spousal abusers
from getting gun permits can you believe
that those people people on the on the
terror list today in america are able to
get gun permits it's something we're
working on and I hope that we'll get
that abolished but passing the law to
stop abusers from household thugs from
getting gun permits they said it
wouldn't matter we stopped 175,000 of
those spousal abusers from getting guns
what a difference it makes it we know
that one out of six women in a house
household with with a gun and a mate
that that goes into rage would be killed
so I've mentioned those things we had
lots of other things I worked a lot on
environment I'm trying to stop the 11th
plague from overtaking mankind that is
global warming and we do other things
that I believe can be of help to people
lit to live better enjoy life more and
and now as you know maybe you haven't
noticed but we are doing a health bill
anybody knows that anyway I think we're
doing a help bill let me put it that way
and so I look at life and I say to those
of you who would consider being in
service and by the way I consider people
that people in work performing
service but because invariably incomes
are far less than most of the people
could get in the private sector but the
loyalties and the energy and I've heard
complaints about bureaucrats and they
don't do this they don't listen I was in
the puppet in the private sector I saw
people one of the great accomplishments
was a DP was our ability to attract
people who would give their souls to the
company to get the job done and make
sure that we were always on time make
sure that we were always accurate I see
I see the energy developed in people who
work particularly young people who work
in government as being more energetic
and more committed in getting more
satisfaction out of their job than those
who make a heck of a lot more in the
private sector there is a degree of
satisfaction you get out of life that is
such a wonderful feeling and so I say to
you thank you for the opportunity to
chat with you a little bit and to
encourage those of you who have any
inclination for public service do it
they because it's it's the most
rewarding experience other than your
personal life family life and things of
that nature and in addition to doing
that I found time in my lifetime they
had one of the largest charities in the
world for three years and to be
fortunate enough to be able to finance a
cancer research center it's in it's in
Israel the scientist in New Jersey was
moving there asked me for help and I
didn't we've been functioning 40 years
doing basic research and making
contributions to people's health and
well-being as we do it we don't have
products but we do the basic research
that permits the product to be
development so my congratulations to all
of you for being here for your
association with Colombia for the good
fortune that we all have to be where we
are and the Opera
that we have to give something back to
this great country of ours thank you all
very very much
you